yo guys ml10 more prestige here  different channels  what's up i'm going to show you how to  get to the mystery box by strafe jumping  here  beginning of die rise i just go in you  see me you should all know this area if  you don't then play to irise  now normally you can't get to the  mystery box via jumping up to that room  on the right but you can actually can as  you see here  you're just going to jump up you're  going to strafe jump as in  just run to the left jump to the right  and you'll get in you can also  crouch jump but i wasn't able to do that  so it's really simple you can get there  you can do the mystery box it's awesome  you can do your goods and yeah that's  about it if you like this leave a like  comment subscribe